et quand je voudrais qu'il nous reste
quelques minutes pour parler de ce mythe
vivant qu'est alain delon on doit lui
remettre une palme d'honneur à cannes le
festival de cannes ça commence cette
semaine et il ya une pétition qui
semble-t-il vient des états unis et qui
est opposé à 7 à cette palme pétition
qui a été lancée courageusement par une
anonyme s'appelle marc des rita b et qui
dit y a pas de place pour les racistes
pour les sexistes et pour les homophobes
à cannes signé pour demander à cannes ne
parle le récompenser emmanuelle barbara
est ce que vous avez envie de signer
cette pétition je suis pas sûr voter non
alors là non non et non et voilà une
illustration très intéressante de l'usaj
que l'on fait des réseaux sociaux parce
qu'il y aura bien des gens qui vont
réagir en disant mais oui mieux que bien
on est en train de parler d'alain delon
et à falloir maintenant qu'on se
positionne en haut rang de manière
défensive pour dire mais donc c'est
quand même un mythe vivant non c'est un
monument enfin je veux dire c'est
absurde en étant on est en train de
parler deux ans plus de deux choses qui
n'ont rien à voir enfin en train de
parler d'alain delon et de sa carrière à
83 ans
voilà enfin c'est faut-il qu'on soit si
jenny steger pas enfin je veux dire
édulcorée pour qu'on puisse bon qu'on se
prenne comme ça à l'un d'eux oui c'est
ça peut être vu par rapport au premier
sujet de même de dédommager des deux
façons soit on dit effectivement les
réseaux sociaux c'est terrible soit leur
ont dit là cette espèce de comment
dirais-je de rage d'interdire et
notamment l'expression d'une pensée
moi j'ai pas tellement de points communs
avec la pensée alain delon mais ça me
dérange pas qu'ils expriment il ne faut
il faut arrêter cette censure que l'on
appellera de vous désormais régulé en
général quand on parle de deux de ses
sujets polémiques sexy mais tu sais tout
le monde des paquets sous la table parce
que tout le monde doit être mis tout et
maintenant cette fois quant à thierry
frémaux c est le délégué général du
festival de cannes
alors évidemment il n'est pas très à
l'aise
parce que c'est bien que ces idées là
sont pas majorité à cannes mais quand
même il faut le dire y soutient alain
delon dès lors que les gens peuvent
exprimer dépenses et contre lesquels on
peut d'ailleurs exprimé dépensé
contraire moi tout me va
le12 l'angle repenser ce qu'il a ce
qu'il pense qu'il a dit en plus de
manière parcellaire ici et là on
globalise tout un groupe tout je crois
qu'il faut aussi faire la part et ça
c'est très intéressant
voilà on appelle ça un grand moment de
solitude mais dans un autre extrait il
parle aussi de police politique pour la
pour la critique est évidemment clair on
revient sans arrêt sur ces exemples je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
depuis quelque temps on a tout le temps
dans cette émission des exemples de
police fictivement de la pensée ce qui
me semble très perturbant je pense très
problématique c'est qu'on est passé de
d'un moralisme intégral qui pèsent sur
l'art contemporain au sens large que ça
soit les acteurs que ça soit bon les
peintres etc
les artistes a maintenant une
interpellation sur les personnes
elles-mêmes césar s'est même pas
l'oeuvre qui est critiquée qui est
censuré c'est la personne elle-même
donc là on en arrive à un degré alors là
pour le coup je vous donne tout à fait
raison de censure qui est proprement
intolérable et qu'il est impératif
d'intérêt ont tout de suite parce que ça
n'est plus possible
et bien moi je dis si vous nous écoutez
merci marguerita b parce que vous avez
réconcilier ce plateau sauf si alexandre
ii vecchio vous signez votre pétition je
démissionne tout bas les gens le
longeais j'ai rien à ajouter le plat
tout s'écroule du coup j'ai rien à
ajouter maintenant tout tout tout a été
dit je crois qu'ici on pousse la logique
jusqu'au bout va finir par interdire
molière voltaire brûler des
bibliothèques
donc c'est une logique qui est un peu
dangereux et qui pour le coup encore une
fois il ya peu totalitaire c'est très
orwélienne de winston smith brûler enfin
reconstitué l'actualité qui avait eu le
passé à la lumière du présent donc
peut-être qu'ils vont retourner les
films d'alain delon
ce soit plus politiquement correct et
écrire en a plus en démocratie c'est la
loi qui interdise sont pas les militants
vous êtes 4 juillet sauf que parfois la
pression populaire ou évolutions du
temps d'internet obligés aussi de leurs
fonctions sur twitter vous êtes assez
d'accord 85 % de ceux qui nous suivent
et qui votent considère que oui alain
delon est victime d'une police de la
pensée qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette ce commentaire qui est fait par
babineau c'est le manichéisme américain
avec les gentils et les méchants ça vous
paraît pertinent 7 cette vision
américaine de des choses c'est soi même
un peu manichéen mais mais c'est pas
faux c'est à dire qu'il ya cette idée de
la vision du monde avec d'un côté
toujours les gentils qui sont selon les
sujets le cela et surtout les méchants
qui sont les autres c'est une vision
simpliste
alors qu'on est dans une époque vraiment
ultra compliqué mais s'agissant de
d'alain delon il un peu comme notre dame
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait attendre qui
lui soit arrivée une catastrophe pour
que vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc
pourquoi soudas on se on se parle et on
se dit ah là c'était un grand monument
mais là on voulu donner une récompense
et donc du coup on s'imagine pouvoir
faire ressurgir avec l'effet rétro
viseur de tout ce qu'il aurait pu dire
pas dire enfin bon c'est troublant même
de recensement enfin j'ai dit non mais
en fait je trouve ça la liberté résumant
sa merci celle-ci mêmes flics dans un
état un pays où on peut penser ce qu'on
veut
il ya quand même des lois pour les poser
les limites mais à partir de là citoyens
payeurs ne dit c'est normal
un artiste qui n'est pas de gauche n'est
pas bien vu une vidéo et des
journalistes il précisé je tiens à
préciser que c'est un affreux mais au
final ça je suis d'accord il se pose la
question que l'on est il devenu de
gauche
et bien voici en avant première la
prochaine couverture du figaro magazine
et comme nous l'avons interviewé assez
longuement je peux répondre à cette
question on va la voir cette couverture
du journal qui sortira vendredi
puisqu'il est déjà imprimé et donc je
peux répondre à la question non alain
delon n'est pas devenu de gauche et vous
pourrez en juger si vous nous fait
l'amitié de lire le prochain film made
merci bien à tous les quatre points de
vue c'est terminé pour ce soir à demain
merci je me dis
[Musique]